all right hi vinito hi so pumped to be
here with you today thank you too
um my question for you to start is how
has it been building your brand through
your journey to fame
I you know I think like what I always
think is just keep my head down so you
know I've had like great wins and it's
it's really been like the joy of my life
in so many ways I feel so lucky to do
what I do but yeah I think I think
sometimes you can work hard and then you
just kind of like pop your head up and
you expect that everything you've ever
wanted is there and I've tried to like
really ground myself and be like
enjoying the journey because really at
any step I've definitely done more than
I ever thought I could you know I grew
up in Idaho and telling anyone you want
to be like an actor as a kid in Idaho
just doesn't like necessarily make sense
so
um I feel so lucky to do what I do and I
try to like remind myself that but yeah
it's been truly like the the greatest
gift
um and and you know I feel like
constantly excited and constantly like I
I get to you know explore myself and and
also along the way I think you know you
really see from like the start of my
videos to now like someone who is really
um starting to like love their queer
identity yeah like it was really
exciting to me I had just come out when
I started making videos really yeah
that's so important
so like I think you can kind of see the
wigs come out and the characters got
more bold and I think I I just got more
and more comfortable with myself and
with being gay and yeah I think it's
just the whole thing has been truly like
a dream in every way yeah have you felt
any pressure at all to kind of be a role
model for others who are in your
situation when you were younger
I don't know if like necessarily role
model I think like sometimes I am like
if someone says a kid has seen my videos
I'm like which one
um
I've seen some [ __ ] Annie probably
doesn't need to be shown again
um yeah I mean I think more I just like
try to show
um you know how much like fun I'm having
and and I I hope that if you know if I'm
not a role model at least people can see
um that I'm being celebrated for being
myself I think that that has always been
like really exciting to me and as always
you know I think that makes my like
parents feel the best I remember like
the first live show I did them just like
seeing a crowd of people that like paid
tickets to see me and and wanted me to
be myself and all of myself
um I think there was like a piece in
that and was really beautiful but yeah I
mean if I'm a role model for anything I
hope it's that I I make people want to
like explore the side of themselves that
they don't feel like they can yeah you
know like if anyone comes like a live
show and says that they were like a
bright lipstick that night or a wig or
like wanted to wear like a fun outfit
I'm like I love that as my legacy that's
great that's yeah that's right what are
some of the difficulties of managing
yourself as a brand
oh my God I think you know you want to
deliver and you you know I think I
definitely get requests for videos and I
think it's hard to kind of filter
through those and and really feel like
this is what I want to make instead of
this is what I have to make and I think
that that has always helped me I really
you know I know that what I truly want
to make will show through in the video
and that hopefully you know the people
have been with me for a long time will
respond to it yeah but yeah that's been
really hard and and just making sure
that you know I I
I still get my point across or or that
you know nothing gets lost in the
internet Shuffle I Think It's Tricky you
know you can think something means
something but the internet can interpret
it in a different way so just making
sure that you know if it's satire making
sure it's like airtight and that you
really like said what you want to say I
think is something that I I try to be
thoughtful about all the time
um and I'm happily thoughtful about it
like I I want to be
um and then I think just yeah I mean
working with Brands I I almost spend
more time on them than my other videos I
think my other ones are you know they're
obviously going to be what I make anyway
but
um they're gonna feel like me but I
think making sure that if I'm ever
working with a brand that people don't
feel like cheated in a way you know they
they're following me for a reason and
it's to hopefully laugh
um and uh or maybe they just like want
to see Terry I don't know I think
they're following me to laugh
um
but um but yeah I think it's like it is
is uh it's making sure that they that
still comes across I think anyways and
that like
um you know I think Max a great example
I I knew I wanted to work with them not
only because they've championed queer
people since they're you know starch
truly but um but also because they were
like we have no limitations for you like
whatever video you want to make we will
support and I think it's just like a
perfect example for me because the the
first video I did for them performed
just as well as my other videos because
it was just like
it was a me sketch yeah
um that obviously had a brand with it
but it was a brand that like you know
championed my voice and right that's
been something that I really like they
set the bar very high yeah so now you
have a lot of exciting projects coming
up yeah I would love to talk about what
potential new Ventures are exciting you
the most oh my gosh so I've been working
on a TV show for almost four years now
um I'm like wow yeah it's four years
it's like it's a slog you guys it's a
marathon
um I think that's something I I try to
tell myself and everyone
um is my agent keeps reminding me it's a
marathon and and I feel lucky to have
the internet kind of right there so if I
feel like okay this is moving a little
slow now I'll go put a wagon and do a
full video but um but yeah I think I
think that is is one of the most
exciting things to me
um you know I'm gonna come back into the
podcast space with my my dear friend
Mary Beth Brown
um this year before the end of the year
so I'm very excited for that
um I think that is kind of has allowed
me to feel comfortable just being myself
yeah which is sometimes the hardest part
for me I feel like I always need to be
like a character or do you know do the
whole thing and I think that that
podcast with a friend like really
allowed me to kind of like for lack of a
better you know let my guard down yeah
um I'm glad I've said that okay it lets
me let my guard down
um but yeah I think that that is that's
something I'm really excited about I've
been working on kind of a variety
special for a couple years as well I
kind of crafted it during the pandemic
so I hope people see that and then
um first time female director Chelsea
pretty's movie comes out hopefully in in
the New Year oh congrats and I'm really
proud of that that's awesome yeah that's
going to be amazing
awesome really excited yeah um I have a
bit of a fun question for you are you
ready for it okay what was your first
big purchase when you got your first big
check oh my God what was my first big
purchase yeah
okay I think my first big check would
have been like I did a live show at
Caroline's in New York and I remember
that check I like was walking in Times
Square and I was like I made it yeah
yeah I'm like I did it right
um honestly like I think one of my big
purchases was like spending a lot of
money on a Halloween costume oh like
really not giving myself a budget okay I
bought
um I worked with this amazing designer
Christopher pillow um hi Christopher
he's currently making my Halloween
costume as we speak got back to work
seriously
um but I was uh I think I did a Kylie
and Kendall with my boyfriend we were
Kylie and Kendall at the Met Gala okay
for Heidi klum's Halloween party and I
was like kind of gave no budget because
I was like I need these dresses to look
exactly like the Versace dresses like
I'm like I want us to look spot on yeah
and we we really did like I'm really
proud of that costume so maybe that okay
and then like I love a bowling shirt so
probably my I have a couple but a Prada
bowling shirt was like a big I was like
I need this and had like a football
player and all this stuff I was like so
cute I gotta get back and what was your
most recent big purchase oh oh my God
it's not this jacket this is online
thank you Dior love you
um this goes back I'm Cinderella after
today
um oh I did get um these yeah I have
some Dior Birkenstocks on there you go
these were my reasons so comfy they're
so comfortable and they're kind of
fashion right they're Couture all right
I'm getting myself a pair yeah you
really need them yeah I was just kind of
like you know what if I'm gonna do
Birkenstocks this is how I'm gonna do it
yeah
um so yeah I needed them unfortunately
good call yeah yeah and my final
question for you yeah
um what advice would you give to other
um Founders or people who want to create
their own brand like you did for coming
up with new content and making it go
viral oh my God virality Is So Random I
feel like any time I thought something
would hit it didn't and then something
that I just throw up is like you know
that's the one and I think that's kind
of like the beauty of it you never know
and and I think you know you really have
to I keep saying like don't judge the
ideas that come in your head because
whenever I do that I feel like I've lost
something that could be really special
um and so yeah if you think something
like at least see the idea through maybe
like write down some notes see how it
could play out and and I think that like
your true thoughts or or things that you
find shame in or embarrassed about or
things that you're like oh God that's so
cringe like other people are going to
relate to that
um it's like a slog being alive you know
like it really is it is like it is it is
I mean obviously like I have immense
privilege but I just like I think the
human existence is there's so much funny
things about it and and these things
that we think about ourselves and the
way that we treat each other like I just
think that there's so much fodder and
and so people are going to relate when
you're saying like I feel horrible and
this is like this video and you know I
think I have so much respect for people
who are able to do that kind of more
personally on the internet I think you
know obviously people have responded to
people who are themselves and you know
mine is more character based so I'm not
necessarily like letting my guard down
but yeah I think you know I like allow
yourself to be
um everything that you are and that
includes
um like anything that you deem not not
right or not normal
um early on someone told me that I
should use less wigs and I always think
about like I'm so glad I didn't listen
to them because I just made what I
wanted to make yeah and had I you know
had I not I don't think that I would
have you know been true to myself and I
think people would have felt that in the
videos so yeah good advice true to
yourself yeah well thank you so much for
the conversation yeah thank you so much
[Music]